The product is 21 m cubed plus 15m to the 5th. Excellent work if you reasoned
through that one. If you weren't sure where to start, always start with the
rectangle. We know this is one number, so this can be one side of a rectangle.
This is our second number. 7m squared plus 5m to the 4th. We want to split it up
into 2 parts. Since we have 7m squared. Plus 5m to the fourth these would be
different numbers. Think about if m were 2 this number would be 28 and this
number would be 90. But we really don't know what m is so, we have to leave it
with these expressions. Next we multiply 3m by each of the terms to find the
area. 3m times 7m squared. Is 21m cubed. There's a 1 as the exponent on the m,
so remember to add the exponents when multiplying with the same base. Our two
numbers, 3 and 7, just get multiplied as usual. Next we multiply 3m times 5m to
the 4th, that will give us the area of this rectangle, 3 times 5 is 15, and m
times m to the 4th, is m to the 5th. We don't have like terms here so we can't
add these together. We have an area of 21m cubed and an area of 15m to the 5th.
This is our total area. And instead of writing your entry like this, you might
have listed your entry like this or rearrange the terms and written your answer
like this. This one is actually preferred. It's in standard form because the
highest exponent comes first. When writing your answers for the rest of this
lesson, you'll want to write them in standard form. Variables are usually listed
alphabetically, and the highest powers come first.